[Music]  everyone I'm welcome to another tech  related video I know this is my second  upload of today but I just kind of let  you guys know I found out a really great  way to enhance the audio of your videos  using Camtasia Studio 6 you might notice  it's really quiet around me you don't  hear any background noise you know  you're my fans are running for my laptop  you don't hear anything  so I can use this on microphone of any  um on this on the camera right here that  I'm using you can use this on the laptop  built-in microphone so yeah I'm  definitely going to be using this in my  later tutorials and I'm definitely doing  a tutorial on how to do this so please  stay tuned for that tutorial you're  going to like it and you'll be able to  use this for everyone out there there's  wishing to do tutorials as well so yeah  thanks for watching this one and I hope  you enjoy and I hope you like this  feature so stay tuned for that tutorial  subscribe  [Music]